blade runner oh  old versus new no  blade runner original it's not even a  comparison people say blade runner 20 49  or play oh my god no blade runner and  and  you gotta i mean going back that that  film has has stood the test of time i  mean when you watched blade runner today  in its many  uh forms right there's so many different  versions of that film from the narration  to the no narration to to so many but  whatever version you're watching  what scott did with that film was so far  ahead of its time and the fact that it  still looks like something that we could  see on the screen today and not be like  well this looks really dated right the  effects the vangelis score  um obviously harrison ford  and you you look at that film and it's a  film that really  uh  expands your mind especially as a young  kid watching that film it that's a  that's absolutely one of the seminal  films for me when i talk about films  that really  created my cinematic soul it's it's  blade runner